on va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
monde
[Musique]
la cause du nous amène à pouvoir
neutraliser les trois dernières
spéciales
c'est donc un riverain qui a eu une
fille d'une donc de gaga et le circuit
dont les spécialités et 10 instituts et
ingo déduire est vraiment notre
organisateur il est pas question qu'on
fasse les véhicules prennent des risques
donc nous allons protéger annuelle et
spéciale je suis le directeur de course
pour cette manifestation
je suis au regret de venir annoncer aux
équipages faut premièrement une sécurité
deuxièmement par rapport à des
agressions par rapport à mai officiels
qui sont sur le circuit je ne les
mettrait pas en danger
donc je suis obligé de mettre fin
des préalables le mans par rapport à
tout ce qui a comme événement
et en terme de placement
ah bah de toute façon le classement se
fera après la septième spéciale
[Musique]
m
en toute franchise 100% satisfait
puisque c'est vrai que ça fait quand
même neuf mois qu'on n'a pas fait on n'a
pas touché à l'auto pour prochain rallye
est il à repartir avec une victoire ce
soir c'est vraiment magnifique et on a
pu s'amuser clairement sur toutes les
spéciales
[Musique]
on prend les mêmes choses qu'on a
toujours fait dès le début depuis 2013
donc c'est une expérience monkey offert
nation est aujourd'hui repartir sur
comme je disais tout à l'heure sur de
nouvelles bases nouvelles
nouvelle vague connaissent une voiture
mieux régler encore mieux que les par
rapport à avant donc on part toujours
d'une feuille blanche et des titulaires
sont de chaque région pourra toujours
d'une feuille blanche et on continue à
apprendre un point d'apprendre à
apprendre
[Musique]
tous les groupes les classes aussi ça a
été un rallye de qualité jeu j'ai bonne
mémoire le guen guérin théodore et
heureusement et puis dans d'autres logos
nous avons quand même troisième tiers
mon avis devrait être un bon troisième
parce que c'est un petit moteur petit
qui monte progressivement mais c'est
matthew main et je parle de l'énigme et
moi je suis content je suis content
parce que les passionnés que je suis
avait envie vraiment debout en france
que le sport tient une compétition dont
bild que les sports automobiles
redémarre
[Musique]